So, since 7 is the number that we're multiplying by itself over and over again,
it is the base number, and it goes here as the big number that we write first.
Now, we have four of these 7's multiplied together so the exponent that we want
is 4. So that means that 7 times 7 times 7 times 7 equals 7 to the 4th power.
Now, there are several different ways of saying this answer out loud. You can
say 7 to the 4th power 7 to the 4, 7 to the power of 4, or just 7 to the 4th.
Certain other exponents have special names that we use, but they're pretty self
explanatory. For example, 7 times 7 is equal to 7 to the 2nd power. But instead
of saying that, we might also say 7 squared, right here. In the same way, if we
have three 7's multiplied together, 7 times 7 times 7, we get 7 to the 3rd
power. But sometimes we say 7 cubed instead.